[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم حلقتنا النهارده
عن السر الذي يعرفه الجميع القدرات
النوويه
الاسرائيليه كيف عرف العالم لاول مره
بامتلاك اسرائيل لاسلحه نوويه لماذا اذا
كان الجميع يعرف ان اسرائيل تمت سلاحا
نوويا لماذا تصر اسرائيل على الابقاء على
هذه
المساله يعني غامضه لا تعترف ولا تنكر
ماذا يجب على العرب ان يفعلوا ليس فقط
العرب ولكن دول الجوار ان يتعاملوا مع
السلاح النووي الاسرائيلي خاصه بعد ان
اعترف وزيرا في حكومه نتنياهو بامتلاك
اسرائيل ل سلاحا نوويا للاجابه على كل هذه
الاسئله ب نستضيف اليوم عالمنا الدكتور
يسري ابو شادي كبير مفتشي وكاله الطاقه
الذريه الاسبق مساء الخير معال الدكتور
مساء النور وسا عندي اسئله كتيره واتمنى
نحصل عليها لان فيها تفاصيل كثيره بايجاز
لان المتابعين الغير متخصصين مهتمين ولكن
عاوزين يعرفوا القصه بايجاز تمام السؤال
الاول كيف عرف العالم لاول مره العالم
يعني طبعا اقصد الدول المعنيه والدول
الكبيره او في دول المنطقه لاول مره ان
اسرائيل تمتلك سلاحا نوويا رغم انكارها
ذلك ا بدايه اسرائيل عندها طموح لبرنامج
نووي عسكري من بدايتها سنه 52 بدات في
انشاء الطاقه الذريه الاسرائيليه بوريون
ديفيد ب جوريون رئيس الوزراء في وقتها دعا
علماء العالم اليهود اللي موجودين في دول
شركه في صناعه الاسلحه النوويه دعاهم
للقدوم لاسرائيل والمشاركه في البرنامج
النووي بتاعهم وفي خطبه قالها لهم تسربت
فيما بعد وهو بيطلب منهم تطوير برنامج
لحمايه امن اسرائيل النووي فطبعا برنامج
نووي معناه اسلحه نوويه لكن التنفيذ
الفعلي بدا من 55 56 لما شيمون بريز
استطاع انه يعمل اتفاق مع جي موليه رئيس
الجمهوريه
الفرنسي لانشاء مفا النووي ا من ماء
الثقيل في ديمونه و وهذا يعني الاتفاق كان
اتفاق سوري للغايه ما حدش عرفه حتى لا
بريطانيا اللي دخلت الحرب 56 معاهم ولا
امريكا وكان
طبعا الاتفاق عباره عن هديه من
الفرنساويين لاسرائيل
لان فرنسا كانت بتعاني تماما من مدعم مصر
وعبد الناصر للجيش التحريري الجز جزائري
في محاربته لفرنسا وبالتالي كانت عايزه
تضرب مصر باي طريقه وده اللي حصل في 56
فكان الثمن بتاعه انشاء مفاعل
نووي يعني له قدرات عسكريه واضحه اللي هو
الماء الثقيل وفعلا بدا بنا هذا المفاعل
في ديمونه سنه 58 ا وطالع وبدا تشغيله في
64 وكان هذا بكوره القدرات النوويه
الاسرائيليه بالضبط العسكريه ليه لانه كان
في قبله امريكا سنه 53 وتانيب لضميره على
اللي عملته في استخدام القنابل الذريه في
ضرب هيروشيما ونجازاكي اعلن الرئيس
ايزنهاور ان الذره في خدمه السلام وقال ان
امريكا هتتعاد مع الدول كلها طالما انها
ماشيه في اتجاه السلام وكان ضمن هذه الدول
الحقيقه يعني كانت اسرائيل وبالمناسبه
ايران
كمان امريكا وافقت انها تديها مفاعل
الابحاث بالنسبه لاسرائيل عماله مفاعل
الابحاث 5 ميجا وات في نحال سوريك في
اسرائيل وفي نفس الوقت عملوا اتفاق مع
الاسرائيليين ان الامريكان يفتشوا على هذا
المفاعل بان هو سليم وان اسرائيل تتعهد ان
هي مش هتحول برامجها النوويه الى برامج
عسكريه ومن هنا كان في التزام بين دولتين
بس يعني هي اسرائيل وامريكا في هذا الوقت
بعدين الوكاله دخلت في التفتيش على نحال
سوريك بس مش على دام
لحد سنه يعني بدايه الستينات الاقمار
الصناعيه وهي بالمناسبه الاقمار الصناعيه
في العالم كانت قويه جدا من زمان يعني
يمكن انا ما كنتش متخيل انه من بدايه
الخمسينات وجايز قبل كده كانت الاعمار
الصناعيه الامريكيه
والروسيه بتغطي المنطقه وبالتالي
الامريكان لاحظوا ان في حاجه بتتبني في
ديمونه واسرائيل وقتها قالت للامريكان لا
ده مفاعل ابحاث صغير
يعني الاغراض سلميه كان وقتها كيندي بقى
هو الرئيس وما اقتنع قوي بالكلام ده وقال
انا عايز اعمل تفتيش وبالتالي يعني عمل شك
اللجنه كان المفروض تروح في نوفمبر
1963 لكن اتيل كيندي وعليه علامات استفهام
كتيره و مين اللي اختال وليه هل بسبب
اللجنه اللي رايحه تفتش على ديمونه دي ولا
لا لكن جبع دي رئيس في رايي انا هو اسوا
رئيس امريكي ضد العرب بصوره خاصه وضد مصر
اللي هو الرئيس جونسون اللي المخابرات
الامريكيه وقتها بقى فعلا بلغته ان بعد
صحيح لجنه شكليه واللجنه رجعت تقول لا ده
ده مفاعل صغير ده ما يعملش حاجه وطبعا كله
كان اكاذيب انضحك عليهم وهم عارفين انه
انضحك عليهم لكن هم عايزين جونسون هو عايز
التقرير كده لكن في الواقع ان المخابرات
الامريكيه والستلايت بلغت انه لا ده ماهش
مفاعل صغير ولا اي حاجه لان كان في مليون
مشاهد تدل على انه لا ده ماهوش مفاعل 2
ميجا وت زي مصرائيل بتقول ده مفاعل على
الاقل 25 ميجا
وات قادر ماء ثقيل قادر على انتاج
البلوتونيوم عسكري وقتها سافر اشكول ديبي
اشكول ل سنه 64 رئيس وزراء اسرائيل في
رئيس وزراء الاسرائيل في هذا الوقت
وعمل اتفاق سري للغايه مع جونسون تسربت
بعد كده الحاجات دي هي لان فاتت سنين
طويله عليها انه اسرائيل لا تعلن عن
برنامج عسكري نووي ولكن لا تنفيه وهي
سياسه بدات هنا سياسه الغموض الاسرائيلي
وجونسون مش هو بقى بس اللي اتفق عليه ده
جميع الرؤساء الامريكان لحد يومنا هذا
بيتبعوا نفس هذه السياسه ونفس الاتفاق مع
اسرائيل ما تعلن ان انت عندك سلاح نووي
لكن حصل بقى بعد كده حاجات كتير ومش عايز
بقى ارص التصريحات والادعاء الاخطاء والى
لكن بلا جدال سنه 86 حدث حادث هام للغايه
وهو هروب ونونو ونشره لصور كامله يمكن
اكثر من 100 صوره عن تفاصيل ديمونه اللي
اكتشفنا فيها لا ده
فنيا المفاعل ده وال معمل المعالجه
استخلاص البلوتونيوم عندهم قدرات كبيره
قوي قد تصل الى ثلاث قنابل ذريه في السنه
الواحده طبعا فنونه للتذكير وكان احد
الفنيين اليهود والاسرائيليين اللي
بيعملوا في مفاعل ديمونه هو مهاجر يهودي
مغربي راح اسرائيل اشتغل في ديمونه حوالي
10 سنين وجم في سنه 85 86 طردوه كان شويه
ظاهر مشغب او حاجه لكن هو نجح قبل ما يمشي
من ديمونه انه يعمل تصوير كامل لحاجات غيه
للغايه واهمها طبعا هو معمل المعالجه
واستخلاص البلوتونيوم اللي كان ست طوابق
تحت الارض واللي لما اللجان الامريكيه
كانت بتروح تفتش ما كانتش تعرف او يعني
تجاهلت ان المبنى اللي بيزوره ده اللي هو
كان دورين بس لان تحتيه ست دوار بانتاج
البلوتونيوم وانا في تقديري الفني هذه
اللجان كلها بتستعبط لان في مليون دليل بس
مش هنضيع وقت دلوقتي لكن في مليون دليل
كان يدل على ان قدرات مفاعل ديمونه كانت
اكبر بكتير قوي من ال 2 ميجا وات اللي
ادعوها لكن في النهايه ان اسرائيل من سنه
64 كان عندها قدرات انتاج بدا تجير مفاعل
وبدا انتاج البلوتونيوم 67 كان عندها ماده
لاول قنبله ذريه في 73 كان في بتاع 13
قنبله ذريه ولو نذكر ان ليله 8 9 اكتوبر
لما مصر حققت انتصار قوي وسوريا كمان من
الناحيه الثانيه اسرائيل قيل انها عملت
حاله الطوارئ و وجهزت حوالي 11 طائره
فانتوم باسلحه نوويه وده يمكن ما كانش
الغرب منه ضرب مصر بشكل مباشر دوقتها ولكن
الضغط على امريكا تهديدا بالسلاح الامريكي
اللي زي ما بيحصل النهارده يعني على طول
القواعد العسكريه اللي حوالين اسرائيل بقت
تمول اسرائيل وزي يعني تضغط على امريكا
علشان امريكا تتدخل بالضبط كده وبعته فعلا
وده اللي يمكن عمل توازن في الحرب بعدها
اما ان بعد كده معرفه اسرائيل انا مش عايز
ارص لان احنا دلوقتي فوجئنا طبعا مش
فوجئنا قوي لكن اثرنا تصريح وزير التراث
الاسرائيلي من اسبوعين بالضبط يوم 5
نوفمبر لما قال انه احدى الخيارات المتاحه
لاسرائيل استخدام اسلحه نوويه في ضرب غزه
واللي بعد كده قال لك طبعا هوكل كل مره
بيقولوا نفس الكلام يعني من من ايام بن
جوريون لشيمون بريز
ل الياهو براك الى ل اولمرت رئيس الوزراء
الى رئيس الكنيست الى مسؤولين اسرائيليين
كتير يقول الكلمه ويرجع فيها ويقوللك ايه
زله لسان انا ما كنتش بقص اولمرت ده
بالذات اللي قال ان احنا خايفين ان ايران
وليبيا تتملك اسلحه نوويه وتنافس بها
الدول الكبرى اللي هي وقالها بالاسم
الولايات المتحده
وفرنسا وروسيا واسرائيل اولمرت كان رئيسا
لوزراء اسرايل كان رئيس لوزراء سنه 2006
2006 بالضبط كده فاذا في تصريحات كتير قوي
ماهاش اول مره ما فيش اعتقد ان العالم كله
ما فيش واحد عنده شك ان اسرائيل لا تملك
اسلحه نوويه الكل عارف ومؤكد وفي جميع
الاحصائيات سواء الغربيه او الشرقيه
اسرائيل مقيده كدوله لا تملك اسلحه نوويه
الارقام بتختلف هي عندها كم سلاح
نووي البعض حديثا الاعلام بيتكلم كتير على
90 لكن حقيقه انا معترض على
الارقام القليله قوي دي لان اسرائيل
المفاعل بتاعها كان 25 كان بينتج قنبله كل
سنه ده في الاول 25 ميجا وات ولكن اسرائيل
طورته من خلال طبعا احنا ليه بنقول الكلام
ده من
خلال سواء ابراج التبريد اللي كانت موجوده
او من المداخن اللي كانت معموله في الريب
بروسيسنج اللي هو معامل استخلاص
البلوتونيوم كل ده يدل على ان قدراتها
اكبر بكتير من كده وقيل حسب بانونو ده لما
قال لك هي وصلت الى ما يقرب من 150 ميجا
وات تخيلوا بقى يعني احنا بنتكلم دلوقتي
اربعه خمس قنابل بلوتونيوم منتج في السنه
الواحده يبقى اسرائيل النهارده لا تملك
اكتر بكتير هي الشيء الوحيد اه ان
البلوتونيوم كبلتني ماده ما بتعيش كتير في
القنابل الذريه يعني تاثيرها بيضعف لو بعد
25 سنه لابد ان انا اعيد معالجتها مره
تانيه لو هي بلوتون لو هي بقى هايلي
انريتش يورانيوم لا ده تعيش كتير ومؤكد
اسرائيل برض وصلت للتخصيب يعني مش هتفرق
يا معالي الدكتور عندهم 90 راس نووي 80 20
150 150 مثلا اه يعني بس مش هتفرق يعني
يعني هي قنبله واحده هي عندها اه طيب طيب
اذا اللي حضرتك قلته انه خلاص في حكم
باليقين ان لديها وهكذا عرف العالم ده انت
قلت كلام اهم من كده قلت انه السلاح
النووي باختصار اللي بتملكه اسرائيل جاء
بمساعده مكافاه فرنسيه على هجوم اسرائيل
على مصر سنه 56 ولانه زي ما حضرتك قلت كده
انه كانت فرنسا تريد التخلص من جمال عبد
الناصر واضعاف قدراته لدعمه يعني عقابا له
على دعمه
للجزائر اللي كانت بناضل من اجل التحرر
بالاحتلال الفرنسي
بتواطؤ امريكي وحضرتك فصلت التواطؤ
الامريكي طيب فاضل بقى السؤال اذا كان
العالم كله
يعلم واذا كان في مبرر ل يعني الرئيس
الامريكي وقتها في الستينات انه يقول
للاسرائيليين لا تعترفوا لماذا بعد ان عرف
العالم كله ان اسرائيل بتمتلك سلاح نووي
ماذا تستفيد اسرائيل من الابقاء على هذه
السياسه ا سياسه التعتيم دي عشان يديها
مبرر ان هي مش مجبره انها توقع او ما
توقعش على على انها دوله غير نوويه على
معاهده منع انتشار الاسلحه النوويه اللي
بدات تنفيذها سنه 1970
واللي كل تقريبا دول المنطقه وقعت عليها
وقعت ثم صدقت ا عليها
لاحقا معدا اسرائيل وكانت هي دي القضيه
الكبيره المعاهده دي بتمنع هذه الدول ان
يكون عندها اي برنامج نووي عسكري اسرائيل
مش عايزه تقيد نفسها بهذه المعاهده لان
المعاهده دي معناها ان في مفتشين هيروحوا
انه هي لازم تعلن عن كل قدراتها النوويه
ايه وكانت لازم تعلن طبعا عن ديمونه
والمنشات النوويه الاخرى فاسرائيل مع
الاسف هذه الاتفاق المعاهده دي ما كانتش
اجباريه دي كانت اختياريه ده الكلام ده
بدايه ب ده بدايتها سنه 70 اه فبالتالي اه
وقع يعني كان في البدايه خالص هم 54 دوله
اللي وقعوها يعني ومنها دول عربيه زي
العراق مثلا هي كانت اول دوله عربيه توقع
الاتفاق
ده لكن اسرائيل لا وقعت لا هي ولا الهند
ولا باكستان الثلاث دول دول بصوره خاصه
لان دول كان عندهم برامج فعلان نوويه
عسكريه وقال لك انا ابعد عن اللي بالتفتيش
ولا البتاع ده ماليش دعوه بيهم انا حر
نفسي المؤسف ان في دول وه من الدول ده هي
اللي وقعت وخلفته التوقيع بتاعها دمرت
بسبب
توقيعها كل الناس بتتساب الله طب العراق
يعني عندها برنامج نوي عسكري طب ما
اسرائيل عندها قنابل ذريه ليه
العالم بيهاجم العراق و بيعاقبه وبيضربوا
وبيغ ازوه
وبيهدد بيكلمها كانت بسي ببساطه شديده
اسرائيل كل شويه ترد تقول ايه والله انا
لم اوقع على اتفاق وخلفته انا من الاصل ما
وقعتش نرجع بقى اني لحكايه الاتفاق
النهارده بقى نقول ايه في بند مهمه قوي طب
انا عاوز استاذن حضرتك لان دي نقطه مهمه
الحضرتك عايوز تقولها انا هل يعني اذ لي
ان انا اصيغ المساله انت حضرتك بتقول
دلوقتي ان اسرائيل لم توقع الاسف لا تعلن
انها دوله نوويه ولا تنكر وحضرتك بتقول ان
هي ده احد اسبابه ان هي لا تريد ان تكون
طرفا في اي اتفاق يلزمها بفتح منشاتها
النوويه للتفتيش تمام اظن ان في كمان
اسباب اخرى يعني انه ما هي لما تقول انا
دوله نوويه ربما ده يفقدها التعاطف لدى
دول كتيره بتسارع في نجدتها هل ممكن مثلا
حد يقنع دول فيها ديمقراطيات انه يجب ان
تساعده اسرائيل وهي دوله نوويه مثلا يعني
فاظن ده برض اعتبار سياسي هو الاعتبار
الاساسي انه بيدي مبرر للدول الكبرى وخاصه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه و وطبعا دول
الغربيه انه رسمي اسرائيل تعلن عن نفسها
كدوله نوويه ومن ثم انت انت يا ولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لما ضربت العراق مع
الغرب ده كله بشكل قاسي لان العراق خلفت
الاتفاق اللي هي وقعته لكن طب اسرائيل
اسرائيل والله ما النتش فده بيدي مبرر
سياسي لكن تجنب هذا الملف كل تجنب هذا
الملف فما تقولش اه ولا لا وكل مره لما
كان بيطلع التصريحات من المسؤولين مهمين
كانت العين كلها على امريكا هتن ولا تلاقي
على طول تاني يوم نفى زي نتنياهو راح موقف
الوزير الطراز ده عن الاسرائيليين ينفوا
ما يقولونه احيانا ويكشف عن امتلاكهم
لسلاح نووي وده عينهم على امريكا شفت
امريكا اه صحيح الراجل زله لسان لكن ين
نفتها اهو ومافيش ما
يجبر يعني امريكا للتاكد ولا لا لان هي
امريكا عارفه والقصه كلها تمثيليه يعني
كلام حضرتك سليم لانه مثلا دلوقتي ايران
ملاحقه من الولايات المتحده والمجتمع
الدولي لانها قالت انا عندي او او كشف
يعني ان لديه قدرات نوويه لو اسرائيل
اعترفت اكيد هيبقى المجتمع الدولي مضطر ان
يلاحقها وهو غير راغب في ذلك بالضبط جت في
النقطه الاهم بقى وهي دي ماذا تفعل دول
المنطقه بما فيها ايران وتركيا مش الدول
العربيه بس اذاء امتلاك اسرائيل لسلاح
نووي يعلمه الجميع ويعترفون به احيانا هنا
تتكلم على نقطه هامه وحساسه وهقول ان انا
يمكن داخل في المجال ده بشكل كبير
و يعني اقترحت عده اقتراحات على مستوى
الامم المتحده وعلى مستوى دول المنطقه
واقترحت حتى على المؤتمر الاخير اللي هو
المفروض مؤتمر القمه العربي اللي في
السعوديه واللي حضر دول اسلاميه كنت اتمنى
انه الناس تهتم بيه لكن مع الاسف مؤتمر
القمه ده ما جابش كلمه واحده عن النووي
الاسرائيلي لما حصل الاتفاقيه منع انش
الاسلحه النوويه دي كانت سنه 7 كانت ا ا
مستعمله يعني معاهده مدتها 25 سنه يعني
كان سنه
1995 تنتهي هذه الاتفاقيه الا لو جددت
وحصل المؤتمر الشهير لتجديد الاتفاق الان
بي تي ده اهي
وا مصر وقتها لو نذكر يعني ايام حسني
مبارك والوزير عمرو موسى اه ا كانوا
بيتكلموا على انه احنا مش هنوقف احنا مش
عارف ايه كان منده بنحاول نستغلها مع
الاسف ونفس الكلام سوريا وكان صوتهم عالي
في الوقت ده لكن جا المؤتمر و وقالوا طيب
احنا هنعمل اتفاق ا بيقول
ان هنمد الاتفاقيه الى ما لا نهايه الى ما
لا نهايه مع ان كان في اقتراحات كتير كان
في خمس سنين في 25 سنه ثانيين او ما لا
نهايه لكن طبعا مع ضغط غربي بالذات قالوا
ما لا نهايه طيب اخترتوا ما لا نهايه ايه
اللي هيخلي دول المنطقه الشرق الاوسط توقع
وهي كلها موقعه ما عدا اسرائيل فراحوا
مطلعين قرار معاه وفي راي انا ده قرار
ملزم وقال
انه على شرط
ان جميع دول منطقه الشرق الاوسط توقع على
وتجزم على لاء منطقه الشرق الاوسط من جميع
الاسلحه النوويه يعني ببساطه اسرائيل
تتخلى عن كل الاسلحه النوويه وبالتالي
توقع اتفاق معاهده منع انتشار الاسلحه
النوويه كدوله غير نوويه طبعا هذا بناء
على ده جميع دول المنطقه وافقت بما فيها
مصر وسوريا ن ووقعت اسرائيل لا طبعا
اسرائيل اصلا مش مش عضو في مقش المعاهده
ماهش عضوه ما بتحضر حتى المؤتمر بتاعهم هي
بتبقى اوزير ولا حاجه لكن هي ما بتحضر
وبالتالي انا الدول دي كلها وقعت بس بهذا
الشرط ان لكن مع الاسف ما قالوش مده زمنيه
امتى هيتحقق اخلاء منطقه الشرق الاوسط من
كافه الاسلحه النوويه وبعدين اضيفه لها
اسلحه الدمار الشام اللي حصل ان اسرائيل
قعدت تقول انا غير ملزمه بهذا القرار انا
لست عضوا اصلا في هذه المعاهده وبالتالي
انا مش مجبره ان انا اوقع
ا كل خمس سنين بيعقدوا مؤتمر لمناقشه
المعاهده دي وايه اللي تم فيها ا طبعا
الدول العربيه بصوره خاصه والشرق اوسطيه
كانت في حاله غضب شديد قوي في 2010 و يعني
الشكل بان سيء جدا ا وقتها تم الاقتراح
بانه طيب خلاص خلينا نعمل مؤتمر لمناقشه
اخلاء منطقه الشرق الاوسط دي في 2012 وادى
فنلندا هي الراعي بتاع هذا المؤتمر
اسرائيل برده رفضت فشل فشل فشل سنه 2015
يمكن انا كنت مشارك في هذا المؤتمر في
نيويورك بعد ما العالم وصلوا الى اتفاق ما
اتفاق يعني يدل انه لا هنعمل اللقاء ده
بتاع منع انتشار الاسلحه النوويه في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط واسرائيل هتحضر ووافقنا حتى
مصر كان مقدمه يعني شروط نشفه شويه لانت
فيها وقالت هيبقى بالغل
بالكونسرت الاجنده هتتحط بالاجماع عشان
يعني انا مش بجبرك يا اسرائيل وبالرغم من
هذا امريكا ومعاها دولتين تانيين اعترضوا
على القرارات ووقف المؤتمر بالكامل وضاع
القرار تكرر نفسه المؤتمر اني برض قرار
فاذا كانت لا فائده من هذه المؤتمرات لان
لا اجبار على اسرائيل انها توقع اذا طب
ايه الحل بقى تعال نبص على
الحل هل اللي انا كنت بقوله ويا ريت كنت
مؤتمر القمه يعني فكر فيه
احنا طبقا للبند العاشر في هذه المعاهده
بيقول ان من حق الدول دي اي دوله اذا حست
ان امنها القومي مهدد من اي قبل طرف اخر
من حقها
الانسحاب من هذه الاتفاقيه ان بالاضافه
لهذا اقول ان وانت كمان شرط ان انا مديت
الاتفاق الى ما لا نهايه ان اسرائيل توقع
على المعاهده او تتنازل عن اسلحتها نوويه
لا ده حصل ولا ده حصل اذا من حقي ان انا
انسحب بشكل قانوني طيب في كتير طبعا لان
النهارده بقى في ارتباطات نوويه كتيره
النهارده الامارات عندها اربع مفاعلات
شغاله مصر شغاله بتبني تركيا بتبني
السعوديه طموحه الاردن طموحه للجزائر كذا
دوله طموحين للنووي مدى تاثير هذا القرار
انا بقول الانسحاب المحتمل من اتفاقيه منع
الانتشار الس ا انا ما قلتش انه النهارده
نعلن انسحابنا ولكن
نعلن النظر في تعليق الانسحاب وممكن قوي
قوي نعمل زي ما روسيا عملت من اسبوع ولا
حاجه ان انا اعلق التصديق على الاتفاق مش
هنسحب لكن انا هعلق التصديق البرلمان بس
هيقول لا انا سحبت تصديقي على هذه الاتفاق
ولا يوجد اي اجبار ان اي دوله تفسر هي
انسحبت او ليه عايزه
تنسحب لان البند ده اتكتب بطريقه تدي هذا
الحق للدوله عشان كده الكلام على كوريا
الشماليه ان هي انسحابها غير قانوني في
راي انا يعني كلام سازج احنا بس عشان نبين
احنا ماحناش جثه هامده على الاقل التهديد
بتعليق معاهده انتشار الاسلحه النوويه
واديني ديتكو سببين السبب الاولاني ان
اسرائيل حتى الان لم تنفذ القرار اللي
اتخذ سنه 95 لمد الاتفاقيه لما لا نهايه
وهي اخلاء منطقه الشرق الاوسط من الاسلحه
النوويه والسبب الثاني ان في تهديدات
وتصريحات على مدى السنين اللي فاتت دي
كلها لحد من اسبوعين من المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين باستخدام السلاح النووي في
المنطقه اذا انا الامن القومي بتاعي مهدد
ولي الحق تماما ان انا اعلن انسحابي او
بلاش اقول الانسحاب على طول اقول
التعليق وبلاش التعليق كمان التهديد
بالتعليق بحيث ان انا ههدي فرصه محدوده لو
اتحلت المشكله دي ولا لا اذا ملخص مقترح
حضرتك انه بما انه يعني بما انه هذا
الاتفاق اتفاق منع انتشار السلاح النووي
اللي وقع سنه 70 وجدد في
1995 كان شرط استمرار الدول العربيه فيه
الى ما لا نهايه يعني التزام بلا نهايه
الا تطور سلاحا نوويا ولا اي سلاح دمار
شامل وان تكون هذا الالتزام على كل دول
المنطقه وتحديدا اسرائيل الدوله الوحيده
اللي بتملك سلاح نووي الدول دي كلها وقعت
ولم تلتزم اسرائيل وفشلت الدول العربيه او
دول المنطقه كلها في الزام اسرائيل بهذا
الاتفاق في السنوات الطويله اللاحقه
فحضرتك بتقول ان الدول دول المنطقه لان في
ناس بيقوللك الدول العربيه والله كده كده
يعني لا تستطيع ان تخالف الولايات المتحده
لاسباب كثيره يعني لكن في ايران وفي تركيا
صي فانت حضرتك بتقول ان دول المنطقه كلها
يمكن ان تهدد بتعليق
التزامها اللي هو وفقا لاتفاق منع انتشار
السلاح النووي لعده اسباب اولها
انه ف السبب اللي هي وقعت على شانه ان
اسرائيل ما زالت تمتلك سلاحا النوويه
اثنين ان في بند البند العاشر بيقول ان
الدول دي ممكن تنسحب اذا شعرت ان امنها
القومي مهدد وانت حرك بتقول انه يكفي جدا
ان في وزير في حكومه اسرائيليه يهدد
باستخدام السلاح
النووي للجوء الدول دي للبنت العاشر طيب
عظيم نتمنى والله رساله حرك وصلت اه اضيف
لها في 10 دول في المنطقه وبالذات دول
العربيه في الحقيقه موقعه على البروتوكول
الاضافي اللي هي
مصر
ومصر بتقول انها لا يمكن هتوقع هذا
الاتفاق واسرائيل اصلا مش موقعه على
الاتفاق ضف حاجه اضافيه لحاجه اصلا في
دوله ما وقعتش على الاصل فيها ورغم الضغوط
الشديده على مصر الا ان في 10 دول عربيه
وقعت على البروتوكول الاضافي انا بطالب
برض وكان اتمنى في المؤتمر القمه مناقشه
ان ال دول دول يعلقوا يعلقوا مش مش هيلغوا
الاتفاق بس يعلقوا زي ما ايران عملت كا
مره يعلقوا تنفيذ اتفاق البروتوكول
الاضافي في بلا بد الحق لوكاله الطاقه
الذريه على التفتيش في اماكن ما كان لهم
ان يفتشوا في في اي مكان واي وقت ولهم
صلاحيه دخول البلد في اي وقت بفيزا مفتوحه
بيروح المكان اللي هو شايفه ان هو فيه
علامات استفهام ا ال الخله وبما فيها
احيانا مناطق حساسه وقد تكون مناطق عسكريه
ودي الخلافات دايما مع ايران كانت لحد ما
هي علقت الاتفاق بتاع البروتوكول الاضافي
بتاعها فعلى الاقل ده موقف هلفت العالم لا
يعني خلي بالكم احنا مش جثه هامده في هذا
المجال ده ده ده احدى الحلول البسيطه
والغير معقده بالاضافه لهذا في حل اخر هو
سياسي لكن هي ؤدي لهذا الغرض
وهي جعل اسرائيل دوله غير نوويه نفتكر
تجربه جنوب افريقيا سنه 92 لما اعداد
السود زادت كتير قوي عن البيض
والحكومه البيضاء في جنوب افريقيا خلاص ما
بقتش قادره تستمر في الحكم
بدون دخول السود في هذا الوقت فجاه كده وط
كان معروف ان جنوب افريقيا بتملك اسلحه
نوويه
غير معلنه بشكل واضح فجاه اعلنت جنوب
افريقيا التخلي او حكومه البيط بجنوب
افريقيا التخلي عن السلاح
النووي الجنوب افريقي ودعت وراحت وقعت
اتفاق منشار الاسلحه النوويه ودعت الوكاله
الى الحضور كشهود على تفكيك الاسلحه
النوويه كان عندها سبع قنابل ذريه ويمكن
انا شاركت في هذا الجزء وفعلا قبل ما
السود يصلوا الى الح كانت كل الاسلحه
النوويه في جنوب افريقيا مفككه وتحت اشراف
الوكاله والامم المتحده اذا ده حل في
تقديري انا اللي هي وجود دوله واحده فيها
العنصرين طب هو الحل ده مش ممكن يتم با
اسرائيل ممكن احنا بنتكلم كتير قوي على
دولتين فلسطينيه واسرائيليه فخلينا
واقعيين دوله فلسطينيه استحاله بالوضع
اللي احنا شايفينه وشفناه النهارده ده
المستعمرات في الضفه الغربيه سرطان موجود
انا هخلع دوله ازاي وبعدين لما بتكلم على
دوله منزوعه السلاح يبقى دوله يعني لاو
سياده لها على الاطلاق خلينا واقعيين نقول
و ما ننساش ان اسرائيل فيها ما يقرب من 2
مليون عربي اسرائيلي غير يهودي ال 2 مليون
دول عرب عرب 48
اه تقريبا وحوالي سبعه ونص يمكن يهودي
تعداد اسرائيل انا النهارده عندي في الطفه
الغربيه وغزه حوالي خ ونص مليون فلصطيني
عربي مسلم او مسيحي طب ما خلينا الدوله دي
كلها تبقى دوله واحده وسميها زي ما تسميها
هم مش الاعتراض يا معال الدكتور انا اسف
يعني ما هو يعني جانب كبير من الفلسطينيين
لا يرفض هذا اللي بيرفض الكلام ده اسرائيل
بص انا عرضت الموضوع ده انا اذكر يعني
عرضته في الامم المتحده
2015 في اثناء مؤتمر معاهده انتشار
الاسلاح النوويه
والحقيقه لقيت رفض من جميع الدول العربيه
ا واسرائيل ما اعلنت رفضها لكن بعض الدول
الاخرى اهتمت باللي انا بقوله حتى يعني
حاولوا يتناقشوا معايا فيه لكن اللي انا
شايفه ان احنا بنركز قوي على دولتين
باصرار اللي انا مش انا مش شايف وجود دوله
فلسطين قائمه يعني الكلام ده لو كان فعلا
هيبقى فيه دوله هو فين الدوله ده حتى
الحته الوحيده اللي كانت مستقله اللي هي
الغزه ادي اسرائيل اتاحتها وعايزه تحتلها
بالكامل الضفه الغربيه انساها دي سرطان من
المستعمرات فين الدوله اذا ما خلينا
نكملها بقى طالما في اثين مليون عربي غير
يهودي موجودين في قلب اسرائيل وموجودين في
الكنيست طب ما نكمل لان اوتوماتيكي
الاغلبيه هتيجي بعد كده لل العرب غير
اليهود وبالتالي الدوله هتبقى دوله
علمانيه ماهياش دوله يهوديه ولا يعني ومن
ثم كل السلاح النووي مؤكد اسرائيل لن
تستمر فيه في
وجود النسبه العاليه جدا من العرب هو بس
استوضح بسيط هو لما البيت في جنوب افريقيا
فعلوا ذلك للتاكد ان هذا السلاح لن يكون
تحت سيطره السود صح وهم مش متاكدين يعني
انه ده ممكن يعملو بايه هيروح فين بعد كده
وبالتالي حرك بتقول قياسا لو اصبحت حل
الدوله الواحده في اسرائيل المجتمع الدولي
او الولايات المتحده لن تكون متحمسه ان
تكون اسرائيل دوله نوويه لان ممكن يكون
رئيس وزراء اسرائيل هو فلسطيني مثلا صحيح
هي بس التحفظ الوحيد على كده وطبعا يعني
نقطه جديده ان احنا نبص لها من الزاويه
ديت هي ا مشكلتها الاساسيه في الوقت
الحالي انه القيادات الفلسطينيه صعب ان
تقبل بذلك لان ده معناه انها تتخلى عن كل
ها لكن ولا العربي لكن الاخطر من كده انه
اسرائيل كمان لا تريد الا حل الدولتين ولا
حل الدوله الواحده عندي سؤال في جمله
واحده مع عل الدكتور وا استاذنك نستانف في
حلقه اخرى ان شاء الله هل يمكن لاسرائيل
ان تستخدم قنبله نوويه تكتيكيه ا مثلا في
جنوب لبنان في غزه او في اي من جيرانها
اجابه سريعه من فضلك نعم وانا بقول في ناس
كتيره قوي خيالها واسع ان القنابل الذريه
دي هتضر اسرائيل زي ما تضر الدول اللي
هتضرب فيها انا بقول له لا وافتكر كده لما
امريكا ضربت هيروشيما ونجازاكي بقنابل
نسبيا ماهياش كبيره قوي لكن ضربت هيروشيما
ونجازاكي هناك هل
تاثرت المدن الاخرى زي طوكيو وغيرها
بالاشاعات والحاجات دي لا هي هم البلدين
دول هم اللي انضربوا اذا لو اسرائيل عايزه
تضرب في غزه مثلا ا هل التاثير هيكون كبير
عليها لا محدود زائد زي ما حضرتك قلت
قنابل تكتيكيه قنابل
تكتيكيه تاثيرها
محدود المدى وبالتالي هو من الممكن جدا
يضربك بق قنابل تاثيرها فقط حوالين ب 5
كيلو الى 10 كيلو ده التاثير بتاعها اذا
اسرائيل مش الناس متخيله ان اسرائيل
استحاله تضرب عشان زي بعض الناس ا ما كانت
بتفكر تقوللك حط المفاعلات الضبعه في
العريش قال يعني عشان اسرائيل ما تقدرش
بقول لا ده سطحيه في الكلام لان
لا المدى مش مش بهذا اتساع الرهيب يعني
جزيل الشكر معالي الدكتور شرفتنا واستاذن
نستانف احرا كثير السفر يعني لما تشرفنا
مره ثانيه عندنا موضوعات كثيره نتكلم فيها
شكرا جزيلا شكرا لحضراتكم ونلقاكم على خير
في حلقات الاخرى باذن الله